just wanna see I just wanna see the
night
[Music]
hollow's recent performance at Red Rocks
with his acoustic version of Lights he
brings a different sound than what most
people think of when it comes to
electronic dance music he is performing
tonight at the lost stage and son is not
only an artist but he's also a producer
a mental health Advocate and his new
single all the highs is out now welcome
to the show my man how you doing buddy
I'm doing great thanks for having me it
is so great to have you on the show I've
been watching interviews listening to
interviews and you are such a positive
person and thank you for being here
today I try to be I try to be I try to
stay vibrant we feel we feel your energy
so all the highs congratulations on the
new song thank you how would you
describe the song what's it about all
the highs you know we all go through our
own personal lows and highs in life and
all the houses are by looking back and
kind of embracing everything the lows
the highs the hello so goodbyes and kind
of accepting that that's life
you know and bring some peace it brings
some peace of mind to kind of accept
what is we're hearing this song right
now it's it's so catchy it's one of the
songs where you you download it you play
it you hit repeat you play it again and
again and again and the song is going to
be featured on FIFA 23 next year yes my
brother was really hot he's been playing
feta forever I told him hey I'm gonna be
on FIFA he said no way are you a video
gamer I I used to be in um when I was a
kid I used to play games but that music
took over and it's all about music for
me now yeah music is your life how was
it with your family and your parents
when you started kind of going down this
road of getting into music and EDM what
was your parents reaction to it I mean
my parents saw how much music did for me
I used to be very insecure I used to be
kind of struggling at school and like
with friends and then I got it I got a
guitar and they saw me kind of flourish
they saw me Bloom into this different
person and they've just been supporting
me
um my teachers were like you know music
is very tough and it's a not for
everyone only one out of ten can make
money out of it and I was like I want to
do music and uh here I am here we did it
Las Vegas in a TV your teachers that are
watching right now he did it he said
he's one of the one and ten but you said
the music gives you confidence and I
think it gives your fans confidence too
because you'll be performing and what's
it like to look out in the crowd and you
see people first up holding their phones
and the lights but then there's people
that are crying with your music what
does that mean to you it's I think it's
the most beautiful connection I think um
if people feel
those kind of kinds of emotions through
my music that's that's the most
beautiful compliment uh I could ever ask
for you know there's there's no words
involved just emotions and that's that's
the most beautiful thing and you do
something that's well do you still do it
I used to do it do you still when the
performance is over because you play the
guitar and everything do you hand the
guitar out to one lucky fan we started
doing that a couple of years ago
um you know how some of those rock stars
have this moment where they smash the
guitar yeah it's like a show element and
I was like What if I just not smash it
and just give it away to someone make
someone happy and uh that really took
off like at my last rap rock show
um I I walked into the crown and gave
away four guitars did you really yeah to
people that just seemed like they needed
it and uh you know it's been uh it's
getting out of hand but people people
are now coming to my show holding it
designs like I want the guitar it's not
about that but it's that's where I'm
gonna be this week I want the guitar
even though you're doing you're spinning
tonight right here DJ what the guitar I
want the guitar so when did your parents
realize that you that you made it
because you're from the Netherlands when
did your when did your mom or someone
say oh my gosh my son did it yeah so
I've been touring here for years it
started in America for me like I blew up
here first I I was like Mom I'm going to
tour an American she's like okay she
doesn't really know what it meant so she
saw videos and still okay these videos
are cool but then there was one song
that popped off in the Netherlands and
it was on the radio she called me and
she said you're on the radio here I've
been on the radio here for years yeah
the states yeah yeah it's like you're on
the radio here in the Netherlands and
every time she hears my song on the
radio she sends me a little voice memo
it's like I just heard your song and I
think that's when she realized
um okay this is this is big you're doing
it yeah yeah son thank you so much for
joining us tonight it's a pleasure to
have you here and we have more Lost In
Dreams coverage Rocky you have more for
us over there